there is this crazy lady who lies for a
living she is the number one liar in
america and she soon will be stepping
down from her lying over at the white
house to to lie officially every day on
the clown network known as msnbc of
course i am talking about gensake oh and
by the way during the uh the live shows
that i did on tour every time i said
saki on stage people had to drink people
were often wasted five minutes into the
show it was fantastic
but jen saki she's very concerned that
elon musk and his desire for free speech
and an even public square in a place
where people can express their own views
without government overreach that's
gonna that's no good we can't have that
does the white house have any concern
that this new agreement might have
president trump back on the platform
well i'm not gonna comment on a specific
transaction uh what i can tell you as a
general matter no matter who owns or
runs
twitter uh the president has long been
concerned about the power of large
social media platforms uh what they have
that power they have over our everyday
lives has long argued that tech
platforms must be held accountable for
the harms they cause he's been a strong
supporter of fundamental reforms to
achieve that goal including reforms to
section 230 enacting anti-trust reforms
requiring more transparency and more and
he's encouraged
that there's bipartisan interest in
congress in terms of what hypothetical
policies might happen i'm just not going
to speak to that at this point oh that
[ __ ] is freaking out you can feel it
you can feel it you see they're losing
control of the narrative they're losing
that's what's happening right here this
is all good today's show i really want
you to understand that this is all
good elon musk's got it he got the
twitter machine he's opening it up and
maybe orange man will be back i heard
mike lindell my pillow guy he was back
for a few minutes then he left again but
the point is they're opening this up and
what freaks out this administration and
the people that want to control you more
than anything else what freaks them out
is that you might have a thought and you
might get that thought out there and
that thought might be against them okay
her line there tech must be held
accountable for their harms how about
the harms that you people that you
freaks have been
smashing us with for the last year with
the economy and the rest of the nonsense
and gas prices and supply chain et
cetera et cetera et cetera so what's gen
saki and old joe biden going to do about
it well the big news of last week and i
was really like i got to get back in
studio for this one they've uh they've
got a ministry of truth we truly are in
1984. they've got a czar and this woman
who's going to be in charge of
disinformation in america this is an
assault on the first amendment like
never before and i'm fairly certain that
if an orange man had done this we'd be
in the middle of an impeachment already
but here is sake
defending the ministry of truth i think
what's important to note here is what
the board is doing which is continuing
what is important disinformation related
work that began under the former
administration the fact sheet that they
put out what they noted yesterday what
they noted in there is that this is
meant to
won the first bullet was about
protecting privacy civil rights and
civil liberties and the first amendment
they said the primary mission is to
establish best practices to to to ensure
that efforts to understand and respond
to disinformation are done in ways that
protect privacy civil rights and civil
liberties i'd also note that the first
example they gave
about what they're going to do is uh is
support the department of homeland
security's work ongoing work back to the
former administration on to address how
and understand how misinformation spread
by human smugglers that prey on
vulnerable populations attempting to
migrate to the united states you people
are terrible but we're winning that's
the point okay so what you they're doing
here is now they've got their ministry
of disinformation and they're going to
try to con conflate it with somehow
terrorist activities and human smuggling
and all these scary things but what they
really mean is you you person watching
this and me sitting right here they mean
people that speak up again against them
the first amendment defends your ability
to speak freely the idea that the
government now has an agency i mean this
is 1984.
orwellian double speak with this woman
the idea that the government has now
decided we're gonna look at
disinformation and see what people can i
can't say this is an assault on the
first amendment the free speech war is
here we seemingly were out of covet now
right we wrapped that thing up nicely
that was fun now the free speech war is
here and you better decide what side
you're on